I couldn't really see the way you guys
enough to judge it I will tell you
though that I went to the armory there
you know that there's a branch of the
windy in the armory and i took my 12
year old nephew and he loved it a lot of
the work is very accessible for example
at the armory what's fun about the
armory too is that you don't know what's
around the corner that's what's fun
about a show like that and i would say
actually that's the case of this
biennial where maybe in certain other
biennials the work was a little more
familiar steel kind of like okay I see
it I see it this work this biennial was
maybe a little more surprising that you
didn't really know exactly what was
going to be around the corner so that's
what's fun about seeing the show
New Yorkers in general feel very close
to art I think a lot of people grew up
going to the museums I think there's so
many artists here and people involved in
the art world that even people who
aren't in the art world might know
artists the idea of having art in your
house whether it's jeff koons or your
friend next door was taken beautiful
photos is a very accepted concept so
people expect to see art everywhere
there's interesting public art in new
york that brings people in and makes
them more aware of art so i think
there's a very close relationship
between the origin are